là il a vient de déposer ses enfants à
l'école dans outremont direction
centre-ville où elle travaille
mais avec un petit détour pour récupérer
sa passagère qui habite à quelques coins
de rue presque tous les matins depuis un
an elle fait du covoiturage gelé en fait
est que l'expérience parce que je prends
ma voiture à tous les jours pour aller
au travail
puis je prends ma voiture toute seule
elle a donc rencontré mimi via
l'application net lift d'une plateforme
qui jumelle conducteur et passagers en
temps réel le jour même coup en
planifiant d'avant ce qu'il ya des gens
qui disent à gauche m 2 le matin j'ai
pas envie de josé j'ai pas envie d'être
avec quelqu'un ça peut être moi c'est le
contraire le fait que je partage la
vôtre c'est moins et c'est moins long
c'est moins bruyant puis c'est un petit
15 minutes mais on est en mai prochain
et la proximité tout ça on sera content
vite fait mauges à personne ou podcast
le podcast d'amis et leïla un podcast
plus tard
mimi arrive à son travail coût de la
course 3 dollars 60 3 dollars vont ils à
76 annette lift l'argent qu'est quand on
est convoité sera présente au québec
depuis 2015 net lift compte maintenant
cinquante mille membres mais seulement 7
à 9000 sont réguliers on est sur une
base double et le membership presque à
tous les trois mois
les alternatives sont en transe pas sont
pas si nombreuses que ça pour beaucoup
de gens donc l'automobile reste le mode
par défaut alors nous ce qu'on dit c'est
avant de jeter la pierre aux
automobilistes
réfléchissons sur une façon de mieux
organiser les automobiles en la
partageant mieux en partageant les coûts
le covoiturage reste encore trop rare
pour réduire la congestion à montréal
sur les deux millions d'automobilistes à
l'heure de pointe
un million et demi de montréalais se
déplace seul mais les choses pourraient
changer
la nouvelle autorité régionale des
transports a décidé d'investir pour
l'encourager un peu voire même beaucoup
de courage tout à fait le sait c'est un
choix contraint d'offrir sur comme
alternative à l'auto solo
la fermeture partielle dans un an des
l'île de près de deux montagnes de
mascouche force la main des autorités à
deux montagnes par exemple la
construction du rem empêchera les quinze
mille usagers du train de se rendre
directement à la gare centrale et ce
pendant quatre ans test rsa parce qu'on
sait pas trop comment s'organiser sur le
tranport gros bordel le maire de deux
montagnes a investi pour qu'une solution
de convois turin choix proposés aux
usagers et net lift y collaborera ce
sera nécessaire selon lui puisque les
navettes d'autobus qui remplaceront les
trains seront insuffisantes
puis nous on a travaillé avec eux là
pour dire oui on lève la main pour avoir
un projet pilote pour l'instant les
solutions qui sont nos mises de l'avant
ajoute quand même 30 menottes à des
étrangers note le retour le soir là pour
des familles qui déjà manque de temps je
trouve qu'on est des gens inquiets est
on en droit des solutions concrètes et
les choses bougent
une autre entreprise de covoiturage we
hope souhaitent tester cette année une
demi douzaine de lignes de covoiturage à
partir de gares situées sur les lignes
de mascouche ou de montagne exemple d'un
trajet stratégique de la gare de train
saint-michel montréal-nord au métro
saint michel comme ça en fait on arrive
à créer une offre une ligne 2
transports collectifs avec les flux de
voitures qui circulent les passagers
avec leurs titres de transport eux
n'auraient rien à payer
mais quel que soit le projet pilote il
faudra d'abord convaincre automobilistes
et usagers du train de covoiturer n ont
pas vraiment pourquoi
tout simplement je sais pas conférence
au monde puis j'aime ça avant la liberté
de changer d'horaire d'aller faire des
commissions c'est sûr que ça se tente
oui vous en feriez c'est sur tout ce qui
est un minimum d'encadrement
s'il ya une explication mesiano cas
d'aurore bien sûr que je le prends
québec devra donner son aval à tout
projet pilote de covoiturage qui fera
partie de l'offre de transport à
montréal
l' agence régionale du transport
métropolitain espère aussi que le
gouvernement l'aidera à financer ce
nouveau service
on est à l'étape 2 de préciser les
besoins puis d'analyser les propositions
qui ne seront fait suite à cette
proposition de besoin est là et je pense
qu'on n'aura pas le luxe
de passe à côté de certaines proposant
le covoiturage comme réelles solutions
de transport morial la prochaine année
nous le dira